Trascrizione: Giulia Fani
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Quanti di voi hanno mai venduto una casa?
Probabilmente, non è stata
una delle migliori esperienze:
infatti, secondo alcune
ricerche di mercato,
vendere una casa rappresenterebbe
uno degli eventi più stressanti
nella vita di una persona,
al pari di un divorzio, cambiare un lavoro
o la nascita di un figlio.
E se ci pensate bene, infatti,
ci sono tre problemi che caratterizzano
una compravendita immobiliare.
Il primo è il tempo: ad esempio, in Italia
ci vogliono circa sette mesi,
in media, per vendere una casa.
E questo è un dato medio,
quindi ci sono comuni dove questo dato
arriva a 12 o 14 mesi.
Il secondo è il processo:
per una persona che vuole vendere casa,
la compravendita richiede un impiego
di risorse e di tempo
molto significativo:
si devono coordinare innumerevoli
controparti dalle agenzie immobiliari,
notai, tecnici, geometri,
le piattaforme di annunci;
si deve gestire tutta la documentazione
prima di andare al rogito dal notaio;
e magari si devono pure fare
delle attività di adeguamento
del proprio immobile;
e infine, come se non bastasse,
si devo accogliere innumerevoli visite
da parte di sconosciuti
nella propria abitazione.
Magari ci vogliono venti visite,
prima di trovare l'acquirente finale.
Un terzo motivo è lo stress:
vendere una casa, per una persona,
genera ansia,
sostanzialmente perché quella persona
non sa a che prezzo
si chiuderà la trattativa.
Magari, inizialmente,
era stata fatta una valutazione,
per quell'immobile, totalmente sbagliata;
quindi ci sono state
delle revisioni, durante il tempo,
che hanno generato
ulteriore stress nella persona;
e poi non si sa quando
si riceverà la liquidità:
ormai la stragrande [maggioranza]
delle compravendite
è soggetta a un mutuo,
quindi una persona deve aspettare, anche,
il processo di approvazione
da parte della banca dell'acquirente;
oppure ci potrebbe essere anche il rischio
che il mutuo non venga approvato
per l'acquirente finale.
Quando alla fine del 2017
ho fondato Casavo
ci siamo chiesti,
io e i primissimi dipendenti
perché vendere una casa per una persona
non potesse essere semplice
come vendere un titolo in borsa.
Se uno vuole, oggi, apre
un'applicazione sul proprio telefono
e con un semplice tocco, sostanzialmente,
chiude la transazione:
compra, o vende, un titolo in borsa.
Però, oggi ci sembra naturale:
ma non è sempre stato così.
Questa è una foto
della Borsa Valori dell'800, credo,
e il termine Borsa deriva
dal Palazzo Herberts di Anversa
dove nel XIV secolo si riunivano
tutti i mercanti d'Europa
per andare a valutare le merci
e i titoli che scambiavano.
Era sostanzialmente un luogo fisico,
dove avvenivano questi scambi
e dove ogni transazione era soggetta
a valutazioni, negoziazioni,
coordinamento di tutte
le controparti coinvolte,
che magari erano fisicamente remote.
E dove il proprietario
del bene o della merce
era sostanzialmente soggetto
a quella stessa incertezza
che oggi caratterizza il processo
di una compravendita
residenziale di un privato.
E che cosa è successo?
Ci sono voluti sostanzialmente sei secoli
perché oggi sia possibile, appunto,
acquistare o vendere con un semplice tocco
sul proprio smartphone.
E questo grazie,
sostanzialmente, a due fattori:
il primo è l'avvento
dei cosiddetti dealer,
che sono diversi dagli intermediari.
I dealer sono dei soggetti, degli istituti
che acquistano un titolo
o un bene da un soggetto
per poi rivenderlo successivamente
ad un soggetto terzo.
E questo è stato il primo fattore.
Il secondo fattore è stata la tecnologia.
È grazie alla tecnologia
che siamo riusciti a ridurre
ad una frazione di secondo
il tempo di una transazione
e a ridurre al minimo
i costi, di una transazione.
Se oggi uno vuole comprare o vendere
un titolo in borsa
riesce a farlo ad un costo
sostanzialmente intangibile.
rispetto al valore del titolo
e della merce che sta scambiando.
Noi con Casavo abbiamo
la vision, e il sogno,
di fare lo stesso per le case,
nel Sud Europa, partendo dall'Italia
Quello che facciamo: offriamo un servizio
di vendita alternativa
del proprio immobile,
a chi vuol vender casa.
Noi, sostanzialmente,
immediatamente forniamo
un'offerta d'acquisto al privato,
impegnandoci noi a voler
acquistare quell'immobile,
e garantiamo che nel giro
di pochi giorni o settimane
siamo già dal notaio e liquidiamo
l'intera cifra dell'immobile.
Dopodiché il venditore esce di scena,
per lui si conclude il processo.
Ristrutturiamo l'immobile,
più o meno intensivamente in parallelo
lo ricommercializiamo,
troviamo l'acquirente finale
e lo vendiamo nuovamente.
Stiamo sostanzialmente facendo
quello che fanno i dealer
per i titoli di borsa,
e il tutto supportato
da una piattaforma tecnologica
che ci consente da un lato,
grazie ad un algoritmo,
di valutare nel modo più accurato
e più veloce possibile
gli immobili che stiamo transando;
e dall'altro di automatizzare
e ridurre al minimo le attività e i tempi
connesse ad una compravendita,
dalla documentazione
alla gestione degli appuntamenti,
alla commercializzazione,
alla ristrutturazione,
tutte le fasi del processo.
Non sappiamo quanto ci vorrà:
ci sono voluti sei secoli per la Borsa,
forse ci vorranno 30, 40,
50 anni, non lo sappiamo;
però crediamo fermamente
che una persona debba avere la possibilità
di vendere la propria casa
nel modo più veloce
e più snello possibile.
Questo richiede un esercizio
che in letteratura di gestione aziendale
si chiama "category design".
Molto semplicemente, significa
disegnare una nuova categoria
all'interno di un mercato
tradizionale presistente.
Vi faccio due esempi semplici,
che penso più o meno conosciate tutti:
se pensiamo al settore del turismo,
quindi dell'alberghiero,
della ricettività,
AirBnB ha creato una categoria
completamente nuova,
rivoluzionando quelle che erano
le logiche del settore.
Lo stesso è accaduto nella mobilità
per i trasporti, con l'avvento di Uber,
e l'esercizio di disegnare
una nuova categoria
pone ancora di più l'accento
sul valore del capitale umano
all'interno di una azienda
nelle prime fasi.
E nello specifico, presuppone due cose
in termini di persone.
Il primo è freschezza mentale, apertura;
il secondo è essere completamente scevri
da quelle logiche di pensiero
che da sempre hanno caratterizzato
quel determinato settore
che si vuole rivoluzionare
e questo è possibile
solo se si inizia
un progetto di questo tipo
con persone che hanno poca o nessuna
esperienza all'interno di quel settore.
Ecco, questo era l'angolo
del coworking Milanese
da cui siamo partiti alla fine del 2017.
Eravamo, come ci chiamavano
gli operatori tradizionali, all'inizio,
"un gruppo di ragazzini",
e avevamo l'idea e il sogno
di rivoluzionare il modo
con cui si fanno le compravendite
residenziali in Italia,
non avendo però mai comprato o venduto
una casa per conto nostro.
E questo è stato fondamentale,
è stata la cosa più bella
e probabilmente il fattore
di successo iniziale per noi,
e penso lo sia tuttora, onestamente.
In generale c'era molto scetticismo
e poca comprensione
da parte di chi tradizionalmente
operava in quel settore
e non capivano né cosa
fossimo esattamente,
né l'entità del cambiamento
che volevamo portare.
Vi racconto un aneddoto divertente:
io ormai abito a Milano
da circa dieci anni;
però sono nato e vissuto a Montespertoli,
che è un paesino qui vicino
che penso tutti o più o meno conoscano.
Ogni tanto torno il fine settimana,
e il lunedì mattina
prima di tornare a Milano,
puntualmente ci fermiamo a fare colazione
a un bar con mio babbo.
E mi ricordo ancora quando,
circa un anno e mezzo fa,
erano usciti i primi articoli
sui giornali locali
e il proprietario disse al mio babbo:
"Ah, complimenti!
Ho saputo che tuo figlio ha aperto
un'agenzia immobiliare a Milano!"
E questo succedeva
abbastanza frequentemente:
ma è normale, perché creare
una nuova categoria di mercato
genera un'antinomia informativa
nei confronti del consumatore,
che non ha più riferimenti.
Ma cos'è Casavo?
È una agenzia immobiliare?
No, perchè non facciamo intermediazione:
noi collaboriamo,
con l'agenzia immobiliare.
È un fondo immobiliare?
No, non facciamo raccolta
da parte di fondi e di soggetti terzi
per investire nel settore immobiliare.
È un costruttore?
No, neanche.
Prendiamo immobili usati
e la ristrutturazione al massimo
va ad agire sulla redistribuzione
interna di quell'immobile.
Noi siamo un "instant buyer":
questa etichetta è nata in America,
quasi cinque anni fa,
per descrivere questa nuova
categoria di mercato.
E pensate che in città come Phoenix,
dove il modello è partito, inizialmente,
un immobile su dieci ormai si vende
senza più una visita,
o al massimo una visita
fisica all'immobile.
Quindi viene valutato istantaneamente,
e la transazione si chiude
nel giro di una settimana, più o meno.
E questo succede per un immobile su dieci.
È come se voi, oggi,
invece di vedere le insegne per strada
dei principali franchising
di agenzie immobiliari,
non vedeste più niente:
ci fosse una piattaforma tecnologica
dove ogni persona,
prima di vendere una casa,
si fa fare una valutazione
e poi uno su dieci, tendenzialmente,
la vende a questa piattaforma.
Quindi potete capire bene
l'entità e la portata del cambiamento.
Oggi noi abbiamo raggiunto
200 transazioni immobiliari,
abbiamo concluso circa
quindi il dato è già aumentato
rispetto a quello che vi hanno introdotto.
Siamo ormai a un rate
di circa 30, 40 acquisizioni al mese;
e cresciamo in modo esponenziale.
Abbiamo raccolto oltre 50 milioni di euro
per finanziare: da un lato,
questa crescita importante,
quindi stiamo investendo sulle persone,
ricerca e sviluppo tecnologico;
in marketing per creare
questa nuova categoria di consumo.
Chiaramente è un modello di business
che richiede molto capitale
per l'acquisto e la ristrutturazione
degli immobili che trattiamo,
e siamo arrivati a circa 60 persone.
Ora, in questo mese,
ne sono entrate circa una ventina
quindi adesso, nella foto
un po' più vecchiotta,
non li vedete tutti.
E secondo me, delle volte
abbiamo sempre fatto delle riflessioni
su quale è stato il tratto
che ci ha permesso
di raggiungere questi risultati,
di crescere così velocemente;
e un tratto che ci ha
contraddistinti tutti
è quella che chiamiamo
"ambizione ingenua":
cioè quella capacità
di spingere il pensiero
oltre quello che sembra possibile,
e di non farsi condizionare
da quelle persone
che tradizionalmente hanno sempre operato
all'interno di determinati schemi mentali,
e poi assumendosi dei rischi,
anche in modo ingenuo,
rischi che un operatore tradizionale
chiaramente non si potrebbe mai permettere
in una determinata fase
di sviluppo della sua azienda.
Una delle cose che mi dà soddisfazione
è fare innovazione assieme a 60 persone
con un'età media di 26 anni
in un paese dove il tasso
di disoccupazione giovanile
è circa il 33 percento,
e dove sembra che non ci sia
nessuno investimento,
dove niente si possa fare.
Ecco, noi siamo sicuramente
il dito nell'occhio
di chi la pensa in questo modo
e la nostra storia probabilmente
implica un messaggio
per tutti i giovani
che desiderano lanciarsi
in un'iniziativa imprenditoriale
a carattere innovativo.
E il messaggio è: fate il salto
nel buio, fatelo bene,
non ponete limiti alla vostra ambizione,
e assumetevi rischi anche in modo ingenuo.
Questo per voi,
perché è un'esperienza
di crescita personale,
e professionale, bellissima,
e perché l'innovazione, credo fermamente,
sia un elemento essenziale
nello sviluppo del genere umano.
Grazie.
(Applausi)